well the dallas cowboys six and nine
washington six and nine and the giants
five and ten all three alive as week 17
arrives and it's a very simple
proposition 4 25 p.m eastern time
kickoff dallas at new york the loser is
out the winner is alive pending the
outcome
of the prime time game between
washington and philadelphia and it's
funny to see all the eagles
writers complaining about their game
being in prime time they want to get
this season over with they don't want to
stay up past 9 p.m covering a game that
means nothing to the eagles it means
everything to washington winning you're
in if you're washington and if you lose
the winner of dallas and new york ends
up winning the division it's that simple
so you're going to have a team that's
either
6 and 10 or 7 and 9
win
the
nfc east in a year where a team may miss
the playoffs in the afc at 11 and 5
chris we're going to have a team
possibly as bad as six and 10 hosting a
playoff game in in the wild card round
yeah no it's it's pretty crazy that uh
we're gonna see a record like that i
mean seven and nine
will go a lot go over a lot better than
six and ten man i mean six and ten will
really look crappy and i think it'll be
look really crappy
for
any case going forward just while we're
on this for having an 18 playoff that
that's where i look at it and go oh yeah
you want to add another team to this so
we can have what four and 12 teams in
the playoffs too and then what like
maybe the best superstar in the game
gets hurt by somebody no no no no no
time out time out no no no no no no no
because the eighth team wouldn't be this
guaranteed out yes you're right you're
right you're right cluster it would be
the next wild card all right so you're
not going to get down you're not going
to get down to 4 and 12. but but what
may happen is three teams tied at six
and ten that's how the giants get in and
then that would mean that philadelphia
beats washington they'd be five ten and
one think of how closely packed they
would be
and and if the giants win it
and the buccaneers have to go
play the giants in january remember that
monday night game yeah sure what the
giants have done to tom brady in the
past you got the joe judge angle there
you got some patriot dna with the giants
sign me up even if at six and ten sign
me up for giants bucks in an elimination
game well i i know i mean that's where
football's tricky the giants did just
beat the seattle seahawks and we're
talking about going into the weekend for
the number one seed too so that's where
it's crazy of course washington played
seattle tough so
uh
that's where the nfl is truly insane and
hard to figure out that way the the
teams are so close and talent level you
know and it's just it's one or two plays
that are a difference there but i mean
washington right now i mean just talking
about them
you know i mean hey i love their defense
all of that but i mean alex smith if
he's not playing i don't know if you can
get behind them at all right now how can
you trust them they're offensively
challenged when alex smith is at
quarterback but at least he doesn't mess
the game up for the defense and the rest
of the football team you know that's the
thing we've seen the last two weeks here
is where the offense kind of messes up
ruins the ruins the chance for them to
win a football game that way so uh that
is going to be key i mean as we sit here
and just go right now with these three
nfc lease teams you just go well the
cowboys are the only one with a
functioning offense i mean they really
are they're the only one you know the
giants with daniel jones and his injury
i mean it's been a bunch of weeks now of
just stagnant offense to where how do
you not favor dallas in this last game
scenario would the way
andy dalton the receivers and everybody
have looked
yeah the cowboys were down 14 nothing to
the eagles came back and won the game
37-17 so the offense is clicking ezekiel
elliott was back to being himself after
dealing with a calf injury and just this
this nagging concern that maybe he's
lost it he at least found it for one day
and andy dalton is getting it done at
the quarterback position for the dallas
cowboys and then with washington like
you said with with alex smith if he
can't play
how can you trust dwayne haskins he got
benched yesterday for taylor heineke
what what do you do and it's not like
you can make things any better any of
these teams that are wondering what to
do at quarterback you can't go sign
someone now because of the covet 19
protocols they're not going to be able
to even walk in the door until friday
chris so you gotta you got to try to
make chicken salad out of whatever it is
that you happen to have percolating
around on your depth chart at
quarterback no you're right and i mean i
would think we see if alex smith can
play at 80 percent he's gonna play this
week i would think he realizes what's at
stake washington football team realizes
that he's their best chance to win and
they'll probably nudge him to get in
there and play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports